the agenda is said hello everyone i'm
brent gough in berlin
in russia if you're openly gay you can
be arrested so
is that a reason to boycott the winter
olympics there
pink and going for the gold that and
more today it's time to talk
in india it is happening again and again
young women raped and murdered from the
outside it appears to be an epidemic
protests
seem fruitless so who or what can stop
the violence well the 2014 winter
olympics
in sochi russia the whole world is
talking about the games
now but for the wrong reasons
in britain there are calls for a total
boycott to protest russia's
new anti-gay law but for the athletes
and for the gays living in russia the
best strategy
may be to play to win in putin's own
court
and national elections here in germany
are about a month away
and suddenly the voters can't see beyond
their plates the green party
is campaigning for a weekly veggie day
in work cafeteria so far the idea not
very popular it's even
becoming a little political other
parties are promising voters
we will not touch your sausage
well we have invited three people today
to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my
first guest is here to make sure that we
do not forget to
eat our vegetables i guess we could say
i'm happy to welcome to the show
paula for easter i've got a smile on
everyone's face here in the studio
with this story um paul you're a member
of the greens um
you're running for parliament you're
hoping to become
a lawmaker next month um your party is
pushing
this veggie day idea so um we're going
to be talking to you in the show about
how
the public is supposed to digest this
idea
my second guest says boycotting the
olympics in russia
will not help the plight of gays
anywhere i'm happy to welcome to the
show
klaus hoistline he is president of the
european gay and lesbian sport
federation klaus you even want to build
a
gay pride house at the olympics
in sochi i'm looking forward to talking
with you about that and
how you're planning to get a building
permit for that
right now considering what the laws are
like glad to have you on the show today
and my next guest says that on paper
india has made
some moves to protect women from rape
and violent crime
and to better help them when they become
victims but
she says on the ground india remains a
dangerous place i'm happy to welcome to
the show
janet walsh she is deputy director on
women's rights at human rights watch
janet when you look at what is happening
in india right now would you say that it
is a
it remains a rape culture that
refuses to change itself i think india
has made important changes
in response to the awful gang rape and
death of a 23 year old student last
december that really
caught the world by surprise and
horrified not just india but everyone
around the world
in response to that some significant
changes have happened
but a lot more has to has to happen to
stop the rapes
to help the victims and to put the
perpetrators behind bars
and i would say probably in in the last
six months
you know when the world talks about
crimes against women
um most people india is one of the
countries they think of i mean let's do
let's do a flash poll here at the table
for a second let me ask both of you as
well i mean when you think about
violence against women
and against young girls right now what
countries come to mind is india one of
the countries
india for sure is one of one of the
countries but
also in for example in germany i mean we
have a big problem
about violence against women still and
many organizations try to talk about it
and
try to put it in the public but we often
forget about it but then because
then we talk about india and of course
it's it's it's
horrible but we shouldn't forget that in
many countries we have
violence against women is it a matter
just a perception
clause is is that what's going on here
it's just as bad in other places
i believe that we shouldn't forget about
people
all over the world women especially uh
not having the same rights and they are
sometimes really traded in in a way that
we cannot even imagine here in europe in
germany
we look down to it uh
african countries in some asian cultures
but even in north america and as
paula said earlier even here in front of
our own house
we have these problems and we have to
find solutions
and um it's good that we talk about it
yeah we're going to talk about to some
numbers
on rape cases around the world in just a
moment but i want to stick with india
for a second just when you think it
can't get
worse on monday police in india reported
that a seven-year-old girl was
raped on a train sometime over the
weekend the rapist reportedly dumped her
body out at the next station and then he
gave her money
maybe that made him feel better we don't
know but in any case the plight of
children and women in india is
not getting better fast enough in fact
news of these types of crimes in the
country
when news is becoming disturbingly
routine
a case in delhi last december led to
furious street protests
and changes to india's laws
six men were accused of gang raping a
woman on a bus
the attack was so brutal she later died
since then a string of other incidents
has kept the spotlight on women's safety
in india
according to official statistics a rape
is reported in the country every 20
minutes
but activists say the number of crimes
that go unreported
is far higher the government has now
set up special fast-track courts for
proceedings involving sexual violence
against women
but seven months into the trials of the
delhi suspects the case is still
grinding on
janet do we know how serious how bad the
situation
is in india when we're talking about
rape
the government could do more to know
exactly how many rapes are happening to
collect data on that but we know quite a
bit
in 2011 24 000 rapes were reported
and we believe there were far more that
were not reported the government itself
says
that rape is the fastest growing crime
that it's growing faster than murders
robberies other kidnaps and kidnappings
so we know that it's a huge problem we
could know more
we could know more i want to pick up on
some numbers um this morning
when um i was tweeting about what we
were going to be talking about on the
show today
i got a lot of messages from people
saying please look at the un's numbers
comparing the number of um cases of rape
in in countries per
100 000 residents and if you look at
those numbers
south africa is number one followed by
botswana and then sweden
but then india comes down on i think
it's a position 51 below the united
states below the netherlands
and when you look at those numbers you
think well it's actually not so bad in
india
but that's from 2010 the latest numbers
we had
um and then if you scratch a little bit
deeper you get back to this other point
are are women do they feel that they can
tell someone
when they've been the victim of sexual
crime well i think women and
sexual abuse against children is a huge
pr problem in terms of stigma
people are afraid to report because they
expect to be treated badly by doctors by
police officers by courts because it
happens so often
and they're also afraid of stigma in
their own communities that they'll be
seen as tarnished that they will
not be welcome in their own families and
community anymore
human rights watch looked at child
sexual abuse in india just this year
and looked at government data on this
there was one study that looked at about
7 000 cases of child sexual abuse
those children only 25 percent said that
they had told anyone and only 3 percent
had gone to the police
that says a lot about people's faith in
institutions and their fear of the
stigma well i mean
it's telling us that institutions are
not working
for for people for children or for women
um
and you're telling me that rape is the
fastest growing crime
what does that tell us then about what's
happening in in that society if
if that's the crime that's growing the
fast well i want to say
it's not just that society we've looked
at rape in washington dc
in canada in belgium in a variety of
countries just by human
rights watch and the un as you say has
done an important work this year
they found that in a global study that
one in three women
will be subject to domestic violence or
rape in their lifetimes
globally and so you know this is a
problem for every single country
including india there are some major
gaps though in india's laws
i think one that's interesting to look
at is a total absence
of a protection system for victims and
witnesses when they have
reported a crime and they're going to
court there's just not a system to keep
them safe
in that process there was a case
recently of a 19 year old girl
who reported that she was gang raped she
had accused the
the perpetrators went to the police
relatives of one of the
the accused tried to cut out her tongue
to keep her from testifying in court
okay i mean yeah that's a barbaric story
and but what i'm hearing here is is the
system
is is failing and i mean paula
you know you are in the political system
here
you know how important it is um to have
a political system
that works for the people um where
is the uproar from the women then if
they are in this culture and
uh there's so many of them why aren't
they lobbying are
where are the women uh well i think in
india there's there's
protests going on i mean there are women
who are who are coming together and who
are protesting against it but it's
it's nothing what you can what you can
change in one day i mean if you if you
look back
in to germany or to other european
countries how
how right of women have evolved in the
past
100 years it was lots of work
and a friend of mine she was just in
india this summer and she told me the
story about a middle class family
where the the daughter-in-law
she's the last uh the last person in the
chain so
um she is uh she's the one
uh yeah who who
nobody's looking up to her but she's the
the last person in the family and i
think that's
um that's how how society then works if
even
middle-class families i mean they they
they're not doing violence to her
there's no rape in this family but still
um there's this woman uh who doesn't
have any rights
and i think you have to you have to work
with with this
and and show that that women have the
same rights like men
equal rights but women are seen despite
their numbers as a minority and
klaus you know by virtue of what you do
for a living um
minorities always have to work extra if
they want
to be well organized and if they want to
affect change
that's true i mean uh looking at india
in particular
as far as i'm informed we don't see
there any any law against marriage
rape uh so i don't know if you can
confirm that probably
law does not forbid i mean look back a
couple of years
it was not even illegal in germany
it took a lot of time to get this
law in place here in in germany and we
consider ourselves to be a really
educated
society so if we want to change the
situation in
in india we have to go really to the
grassroots and
educate the people that the military
rape there
is not okay so if you can educate the
people there and
probably we cannot do that from here but
that is something that has to happen
what can come from outside well i
actually like to talk about what's
coming from inside and there's a lot
and so i think we need to give credit to
the great women's rights movement of
india
it doesn't perhaps always get as much
profile as as they deserve
but there are amazing activists who've
been working for decades
who are the reason behind the good
changes we've seen so far
we do have a law as of this year that
expands the definition of rape
that guarantees victims medical services
that does a number of things that can
uh improve the situation and that really
is largely thanks to the great activism
of women's rights
activists there but it still seems like
if they are
out there trying to make a difference um
it almost feels like it's in vain
because we're hearing about these
horrendous crimes
all the time is it i mean is it a matter
of perception
is it a matter of numbers looking at
india or anywhere
there are a number of things that have
to happen to bring those numbers down
and ultimately it comes down to
leadership in governments really
taking a stand that this has to stop we
need better laws
we need those laws and policies those
laws have to be
enforced right and exactly and then and
then then we're talking about the police
officer and almost
all police officers in india are men
and how are you how i'm just trying to
imagine how a society
is going to stop rape when
the first person or the second person
that you talk to
after being raped is a man and you're a
woman
how do you a well-trained man can do a
lot better than the poorly trained or
insensitive men or women police officers
we're seeing handle
cases right now so we do think you need
a bigger investment
in the laws in the enforcement and also
in accountability so
when a police officer man or woman is
failing to take
a charge or to help a woman get
connected to the services she needs
after she's been raped
that person needs to be held accountable
that might be through losing their job
it might be through being prosecuted but
there has to be accountability
but we we're really pushing for training
of police
and also for staffing i mean we see
there's a massive backlog in the court
system we understand there's a need for
more more judges more trained judges and
more
investment in the the judicial system
and legal system overall
the the speed courts these fast courts
for rape um
that was established i think they were
established back in december
these courts are very slow they're not
fast they're only fast in name
even if they will be fast i mean if i
hear stories that
a judge advises a rape girl or a
raped woman to marry the the man who has
just raped her
just to solve the problem i'm asking
hello
there has to be done some education also
on on the higher levels
it's not only the police it's it's
really the judges as you say
um that have to to change
and they have they have the laws they
have to enforce them
and um if you
are told oh you're raped yeah terrible
story but
why don't you uh marry that guy is that
the solution well i mean
i mean right it it's not assuming that
it's cynical
but i think i think one reason why india
gets so much attention is because india
is such a big
country and because india is changing so
quickly
isn't india a classic example of
of the old system clashing with the new
system now and
men being incredibly frustrated
by what's happening and feeling like
they're no longer in control
you know i think india is an example of
remaining
inequality between men and women and
that is at the heart
of all forms of discrimination and
violence against women in india and
elsewhere
and so yes there are situations where
for example
women in india in some regions are not
entitled to
their inheritance rights they are not
equal in the workplace
they're not equal at political levels
there's a variety of ways that
that women and men are unequal in india
and that society is accepting that just
too much
and we know that in countries and places
where there's a great degree of social
and economic inequality
violence is more likely to happen we've
talked you know a lot about what's going
on inside
what can come from outside you know
we've got
europeans here at the table what can
europe give to india
to help the plight of women we can hear
from the europeans but
what would you like to see though first
there are things that are already
happening
not necessarily the european angle that
as well but
there are international systems to
support countries around the world
in improving their response to violence
against women these are coming from the
world health organization to help
say the forensic doctors who is
currently in india are not treating
victims well enough
there are ways that um sort of law
reform police training judicial training
so
u.n institutions have a very important
role to play okay but i mean i'm giving
you a great opportunity
here um janet because you know you've
got paula at the table
she's in government you know in theory
you know i mean there is an election an
election next month in theory you know
she could be
um in parliament with the the governing
powers
let me see paula actually can you do
something for women even beyond india
in the united states around the world
women who are confronting discrimination
and violence against women
germany does have an important role to
play globally so what's up
uh well i think with india i mean you
already said things what
what germany or europe can do i mean of
course we can
we can help the the movement there you
know that we
support the the women's organization and
bring them together with women's
organizations here or with politicians
or
other government here of course you can
support
small project or projects with money
or training like we said with policemen
but i think changing changing the
society
um i don't think that you can can do
that from from the outside because
let me pick up this i want to i want to
be honest yeah and it's good we have to
be honest because
that's going to that's going to take us
to our next topic which is
russia and the olympics and people
wanting to change
russia by exerting pressure from outside
i mean it's what everyone's talking
about right now russia the 2014
winter olympics and what happens if you
plan to attend and you happen to be gay
russia's interior minister confirmed
this week that
the country's controversial anti-gay law
will be enforced at the sochi games now
that means
gay athletes could be arrested for
holding hands
on the street the the same is true for
sports reporters covering the games and
even for coaches there are
gay coaches out there so what should the
world do
should it boycott or should go ahead
with the games
knowing that they could easily morph
into a battleground over human rights
and
what does the ioc need to change to make
sure that future
host countries understand the rules
affair play and justice
applied to everyone not just to the
athletes
the law russia introduced in june has
sparked protests both in and
outside the country what russia calls
homosexual propaganda is now
illegal so are gay pride marches
people breaking the law can be fined or
locked up for up to 15 days
foreigners who take part can be deported
russia is an increasingly hostile place
for gays and lesbians to live
attacks on them are not uncommon but the
country is making a big effort to
promote itself as modern and welcoming
especially in the run-up to the 2014
winter olympics in slochi
some activists say the game should be
boycotted in protest of the law
but others say taking part is the best
way to achieve
change yes so here we are with this
topic
again clouds of wanting to change
society
standing on the outside is the boycott
the best way to do that i don't think so
i mean we have seen in the past that
boycotts have never
ever worked in a quick way they
never ever changed something immediately
and we are in close contact with the
activists in russia
we have a membership organization based
in in russia
and they share our opinion that if we
call for a boycott they wouldn't benefit
from that
what they need is some people who have
the courage who are brave enough to
speak up
and to be there and show flag and that's
what we try to do
and that is why we don't support uh
a boycott of the athletes in this winter
games
yeah but aren't you go if you're going
to sochi
you are endorsing the system that you're
going to be in i mean
and with a boycott isn't that a boycott
i mean correct me if i'm wrong with this
paula is a way
of saying we do not accept what you're
doing
well i'm not i haven't finally decided
if i
if i think a barcode is a good way but
i'm
if the ioc was the organization like a
very political organization
who would say we will go there we will
protest and i would say okay then maybe
um
doing the olympic games there and
protesting would be the
the right way but i don't see the ioc
doing that but the ioc
itself we all know is very political
inside right
i mean you know you said you want to be
honest about how things work
the ioc is a very political organization
yes but now they say um uh
before the olympic games they say we are
we're not political
and we we don't tell our athletes to do
this or to do that and
so i i think now if we if the olympic
games take part there
not much will happen i mean maybe there
are some some protests but i don't
see the the big screen in the world
where the protests uh
will be on and i don't see changes in in
russia so
um and and i think also the
the the governments and and the the
the the teams i mean they also have a
responsibility for their athletes and i
mean now they're sending them
to a country and if you're if you're gay
then you're not allowed to to show it
because then maybe you you will be
imprisoned so
yeah i mean you know wow thank you ioc
for you know giving the athletes a
country where they could you know get
arrested
in for being themselves what did you
expect well i wanted to say that
your reflection on kind of the position
of the ioc reflects that for the last 12
years under the current leadership
they've really just been
very tepid about human rights abuses
about discrimination and we think that
that can change and should change
there's an election happening next month
for the new president of the ioc for the
next 12 years
we feel that this is a time to really be
much more
overt about their commitment to the
their own olympic charter that says
it's about human dignity and about
ending discrimination
and so we're really you know at human
rights watch we're pushing for
the new leadership and even the current
leadership to
firmly commit to human rights to having
a method of assessing a human rights
record of a host country and monitoring
it going forward would you say
janet from your position have national
governments are
are they letting the athletes down
by allowing the athletes to go into this
environment
knowing that it could be dangerous for
them our perspective is that the russian
government
is letting the world down by having laws
like this these are oppressive and
discriminatory laws
and that that should change and the ioc
has a responsibility
as the body that deals with it country
by country you know i think that there's
a decision to be made
human rights doesn't at this point
support a boycott
but what we think should happen is
getting um
using this event as a an illustration of
the massive human rights problems in
in russia including the discrimination
against case what do you think the
german government says we've got a
politician here what should the german
government
be doing about this well i'd love to
hear from your german spokespeople here
they're better placed than i am i mean
what
what can berlin do
i mean of course they can talk and uh
but i mean that's that's what have been
going on in the past years and nothing
much has changed so and now uh
our foreign minister vesta vale he said
um
he's not in favor for a boycott but he
thinks
we should use it as a platform but he
hasn't said
more about what what to do but you want
to be in power you want to be in power
next month in in germany right and
you're saying that angela merkel
the cdu uh the fdp
that they have they've failed us in the
policies with russia
so can you give us an idea of what you
guys would do differently
to make mr putin see the light
well i think probably we we won't be
able to to
to make putin see the light but
if if we come to the decision that um
he's not responding to talks then then
we also have to talk about how
how we work together with russia and
then
you know not not say he's he's violating
against human rights but then
uh like on an economic way for example
working together so that's
that's that's what happens we have
such a lot of talks and miss smacker
says oh yes um
it's not okay what are you doing there
mr westward is doing the same and all
the other politicians that we have heard
so yes actually it's really not okay but
i don't see anything really happen
and i mean what they can do they can put
pressure on the national olympic
committees which are part of the olympic
organization
to put more pressure on on the ioc the
ioc card
definitely has to be updated they have
to
include other kinds of discriminations
as
like criteria to as knockout criteria
for
uh host cities and to go further i mean
we had to 2008 the olympics in china we
had a big discussion about human rights
anything happened did anything change
until now
and do we now talk about human rights in
china it has been completely forgotten
and that will happen after the sochi
games
in the same way i mean and even if it
would have happened what uh
the high officials uh in in russia told
uh the ioc several days ago oh no uh
don't worry i mean for the
duration of the olympics we will not
apply this law and that has been then
completely canceled you don't want to
boycott i mean you're willing to send
the athletes in to an environment where
they could get arrested
so what are you going to tell them to do
act
straight while you're there well i mean
it's always if you go to a different
country you have to respect the law in
in place because otherwise uh you might
face the consequences that's
that's a matter of fact and we cannot
change that and what about this pride
house
that you want to build how's that going
to happen the pride house as we have
done it like
uh during the uh european championship
of
uh football here in europe in ukrainia
and poland
which has been completely independent
event that
the eglsf has organized there
will not be possible in in russia
because we simply will not have
uh any permission to do that
so what we can do what can you do and
what we're talking about is uh
talking with national olympic committees
if their organization can host it in
their own quarter so
that is part of the national olympic
um the organization right but you're
still
it's almost like the underground
railroad a little bit what you're going
to try to keep it secret
well it is probably not not meant to be
a secret because once you do it
you have also to to tell it at least to
the athletes and and to potential
supporters who go there yeah so we have
to publish it anyway
but i don't think that russia would send
a police
force to to close down just for for
example
the dutch or the the belgium uh ump
quarter
i don't think that russia would risk
that uh that much
of losing its face okay that's one point
paula let me ask you do you think
politicians need to pull back
when they're looking at the olympics and
not
treat the olympics as a political event
because when they do
you guys end up in situations like
you're in right now where you have to
make uncomfortable
well i think the the olympic games are
something special and i mean you have
the
you have the culture you have the
olympic spirit so and it's
it's is that spirit it's also human
rights
yeah and it's it's also it's it's it's
not just some
event some some sport event it's the
olympic games and
that's also something political and uh
so the the io ioc
has also to talk about it i mean they
can just say oh the olympic games are
bringing together
people from all over the world and it's
it's it's nice
but then they also have to act to it and
but they have to act
uh to it before they decide where the
olympic games are going to be
so they have to say if the olympic games
are somewhere
uh then you have to you have to um
you have to assign to the to the human
rights and if you don't do that then we
do the olympic games
for the ioc apparently the money the
money has a higher value than the human
rights
because otherwise how can you explain to
people that they don't care
where they have the the games i mean if
i would be
responsible in the ioc that would be a
knockout criteria
your country is not respecting the human
rights because your law is
not respecting the equality
and you're discriminating people then
you won't get it well the only power you
have right now though
like stephen fry has said is a boycott
because that's the only way now you can
now it's too late i mean
we have to not to change russia because
we cannot do that right but we can
change
the ioc ioc all right good all right
well listen we need to move on um we're
talking about politics and that's going
to take us to our third topic
germans go to the polls on september
22nd in a national
election now the economy the eurozone
crisis
personal data protection and the nsa
spying scandal they all rank as the top
concerns and don't forget about eating
more vegetables now the green party in
an effort
to win more votes we've got them smiling
in the studio again
has made the lunch menu a
political semi-hot potato
germany's green party wants to be back
in power after the september elections
it was last in a ruling coalition in
2005
but one suggestion in the party's
manifesto hasn't gone down well
the greens say they want public sector
offices to cut down on meaty meals
by offering more vegetarian dishes in
canteens
the party would even like to see veggie
days when no meat is served
in a country where people eat around 60
kilos a year on average
the idea of legislating the traditional
lunchtime sausage
has many germans up in arms
all right i mean we've you know we've
been a little tongue-in-cheek about this
this campaign today
in the show paula but um
how can a campaign for
having a veggie day at work how can that
be put on a platform
when you have something like the euro
crisis
still breathing down your back and you
want to be in power
i don't know you have to ask the the
build newspaper who uh
put this uh on the front page but they
took it from the greens platform they
didn't create
it's one sentence in our uh whole
platform that has
300 pages and so of course it's one
thing
uh we that's that's our opinion
so we we stand for this but yeah i think
it's three
sentences but anyway it's three we don't
want to argue over small potatoes here
yes but but we
we we were we were also wondering about
why
is this topic now uh now
discussed so much i mean there are so
many other things that are way more
important
so it's the media
that's well we didn't we didn't i mean
it's on our platform but
we discussed and decided about three
months ago
so it's it's nothing new and um
i think it's i think it's something
interesting you know you can put on the
newspaper
everybody talks about it um because
about the the whole nsa
thing and and the the financial crisis
it's it's not a topic where all the
people are discussing about it but it
is a topic about freedom
and you know germany right now is up in
arms about
protecting personal data personal
freedom
and you've got a lot of politicians who
are saying well if you start
by telling me that i at work i i can't
eat
meat on thursday then you're going to
tell me that i can't drive my
car on sunday because that's good for
the environment
and the green party
suddenly looks like the party that is
taking
rights away from people well
i think many people discuss about it now
um as it's a thing about freedom
but um they for they they forget what we
actually wrote in our platform
and we never said we want to we want to
forbid
meat or we want to forbid that you can
eat meat because we we
we can do this i mean we can only make
laws
where we have the the right to do it and
um
we can only say um you know we can
advertise for it and we can say
it would be good if you have a one day a
week in in your canteen where you don't
sell meat so that people can think about
their meat consumption but we can forbid
it and
we also we don't want that but we want
to you know get a discussion about meat
consumption okay we want to get a
discussion about meat consumption
i mean yeah it's a good idea let me ask
you guys here at the table is is that
something
a respectable political party
in the year 2013 in the middle of europe
should be throwing out into the ring
when elections are around the corner
i was wondering yourself why that has
had been on your platform i mean as
healthy it might be to eat more salads
more
vegetable and not but does that really
really have to be part of a political
program
i mean aren't we educated enough in
germany to
know that we should eat more vegetables
more fruits maybe
every announce some somehow at
me i mean many people have to do that
anyway because they are living on on
hearts for uh money from from the
government welfare benefits
and welfare benefits so they cannot even
afford to
to buy meat for seven days in a week and
i mean but it's not about money if
you're talking about
environment then i
wonder shouldn't we then talk about
apples coming from new zealand
grapes which are coming from argentina
eating the the spanish carrots while we
have them
growing here in germany wouldn't that be
much more
important if you talk about the
environment because then you have also
the
pollution to get all this stuff here in
germany
i mean it's it's it's not a health
discussion um
because i i think that people should
decide themselves if they
they want to drink alcohol or if they
want to eat healthy or not
that's that's their um decision it's
in our program it's it's a discussion
about environmental and
and climate issues because um
those things you just said they're also
part of the platform
but one big problem is the meat
consumption in the world because it
takes
it takes lots of room and especially in
africa and latin america
there are many areas um where they grow
food like soy and maize right and for
animals to eat so we can eat the animals
and it takes lots of space it takes lots
of water
drinking water so many people
don't don't have the space anymore in
america and africa to grow their own
food
so is that a topic that's going to get
you elected though
when you know you're having to open up
your wallet right now and save
greece possibly for a third time in the
eurozone crisis
well it's one it's one of our topics and
um
so we have many topics and i know that
some people
maybe don't like it but we don't write
our program so that
people like us it's our opinion we want
to get elected though
yeah of course but we are a big party um
we have
60 000 members and everybody can can
can write something and then we discuss
about it at our party meeting so
it's not only 10 people who decide about
what we what we will
run for but it's the whole party and
this is one thing that's that's
that's important uh okay for also for
hunger and poverty in the world
and also for climate change well i'm a
big supporter of full disclosure so i'll
ask
everybody at the table is anyone here a
vegetarian
no i am are you okay well she's with the
green party okay
so maybe if you had you know a table
full of vegetarians maybe
you know the the appeal of of the the
platform
would be different um i know we haven't
heard anything from janet about this
idea janet what do you think about a
veggie
thursday at work well i'm here on behalf
of the human rights movement and there's
a right to food but there's not exactly
a human right to brought forest
and so i think there's a balancing to be
made here and you know i actually think
it could be a health issue legitimately
so governments and political parties
have a role to play in promoting public
health and promoting a healthy
environment
including at a time when there's an
economic crisis i think this actually
can relate to that
exactly how it's done is a different
question we've seen in new york a much
harsher measure than what you're
proposing on sodas
that where mayor bloomberg has lost
twice in two different courts his effort
to limit the size of
sodas there so it hasn't gone done well
in my
society but you're not actually
proposing a ban but aren't you aren't
you surprised
we're running out of time but aren't you
surprised that this a veggie
day is on a platform in a society where
smoking
is still accepted and it's not such a
taboo as it is for example in the united
states
well that may what it may be in the
other 300 pages something about smoking
i don't know i haven't read your
platform but
no i think i've seen my own government
play a role in
in many areas in promoting healthier
eating and promoting the end of smoking
for some people
and and changing how people live to
become healthier
and i think that's legitimate when when
you want to spark that debate which i
think is a good debate
um i feel like it's the unfortunate the
news that i've seen in the debates i've
seen
have really been about freedom yeah
we're gonna have to wrap it up there um
thanks everyone for coming on the show
and i bet after election day
we're gonna be talking about um if
people are eating bratwurst or not here
at germany all right that's gonna wrap
up
the agenda this week don't forget you
can watch the show again on our website
and on youtube and
don't be shy tell us what you think
about the show our inbox is always open
you see the address right there and you
can also reach us on facebook and
twitter
at brentgoth tv all right i'm brent goff
in berlin
join me next time when i set the agenda
you